so going back to your first acting job
now i know you have a credit um from 94
for but i understand it was a psa you
did against racism is that your first
that was my
first commercial yes
my first commercial was a psa um
against racism it was a beautiful
commercial because
there was a swimming pool and there were
actors from all different types of
backgrounds and we were all very young
at the time
and
we had to walk backwards into the water
into the pool into the sort of black
pool
and then they would play it forward so
it looked like we were coming out
of
of the water coming out of in in on the
water where it projected all these
negative
racist images that we were sort of
breaking through
it's a beautiful commercial i still have
a copy
so that was my first uh
gig in this business
and how did you get that
auditioning
yeah uh auditioning
i had always been approached as a kid um
all over town
that i should pursue acting you know
random people would come up to my mother
and be like your son should be in
in business and she was like i don't
know what that is and no he's going to
school
so um one day i was
on the bus home
the metro and this lady approached me
and she's like you should call my agent
she gave me her
agent's phone number
but i was like 13.
so
i called the agency and they said yeah
send us your picture and resume
but 13 i didn't really know what that
was and and i didn't really have anyone
in the business who could inform me what
that that was so i never pursued it
and
finally when i was 18
i held that number in my journal i had a
little journal as a kid and when i was
18 and i was finally pursuing acting and
i had an agent and a manager i was going
through my journal and i realized that
the agent
that the lady had
asked me to call was my agent
at the time that i was 18. wow so i felt
like it was just meant to be eventually
it was gonna get there
that was
quite a surprise i was like whoa
they're my agents
five years later but they're my agents
so